since Tuesday night's election results
I've seen companies in the education
space so think of the folks who send you
your monthly bills on your student loans
private companies that originate student
loans and for-profit colleges their
stocks have absolutely skyrocketed
navient Corp which sends monthly bills
to about 12 million Americans every
month on their student loans their stock
jumped by about 20 percent Sallie Mae
which is the nation's largest lender of
private student loans their stock jumped
up by a similar amount DeVry Education
which is a for-profit college company
one of the biggest in the country they
were sued earlier this year for
allegedly defrauding students their
stock jumped by more than eight percent
the Obama administration has demonized
these companies investors think that
that'll end once Trump takes office
Donald Trump has said that he wants the
federal government out of the student
loan business the problem is that 9 out
of every 10 new student loans come from
the federal government anyone who wants
to go to an accredited college can get a
federal soon alone and the private
sector isn't as I guess not as welcoming
or forgiving of borrowers previous you
know blemishes borrowers would expect to
pay more on their student loans less
friendly terms there may be folks who
will be denied loans to get a college
education you could see a world where if
it's harder to get a loan to go to
college College is already so expensive
and so few families have saved up enough
to pay for college tuition that you
could see fewer Americans getting higher
education